if public school is supposed to be the
good socializer
one wonders why it's done such a poor
job of it
many lies are told by those who want to
stop you from making the choice to
educate your own children they'll say
for example that
homeschool kids don't perform as well
academically as public school kids
well research has consistently shown
that to be a lie they'll say that
parents aren't as qualified to teach
their own children that's
clearly untrue what a child needs most
of all is not tutoring from
experts in every academic discipline
he's not going to receive that in public
school anyway
but a personalized educational
experience tailored to his own unique
needs
nobody's better equipped to provide that
than his parents but
by far the biggest lie about
homeschooling and also the most common
argument made against it
is that homeschool kids aren't properly
socialized
this line is especially ironic now as
public school kids have been trapped in
their homes behind computers
for a year but putting the lockdowns
aside the claim that homeschooled kids
won't develop the excellent social
skills of public school children
is absurd for a number of reasons the
first being that public school kids
don't have excellent social skills or
any social skills at all
to the people who make this claim i want
to ask have you spent any time
you know in society maybe you've noticed
that
though we are a society mostly populated
by people who spent their formative
years in public school
we are also a society plagued by
crippling anxiety neuroses ample
insecurities
all sorts of antisocial behavior if
public school is supposed to be the good
socializer one wonders why it's done
such a poor job of it
in the schools themselves we're told
that bullying is an epidemic
we know that drug and alcohol abuse are
major problems
childhood suicide was on the rise even
before the lockdowns
accelerated the trend sure you may have
met an awkward homeschool kid in youth
group
when you were in seventh grade but if
you can draw sweeping conclusions based
on that anecdotal evidence
what kind of conclusion should we draw
about public school based on
quite a bit more evidence it seems that
experience and evidence points to public
school
not home school being the environment
that really stunts
the development of social skills why is
that
well it's all about social cues in
public school
where is the child getting his social
cues from what or whom
is he learning social skills from the
other students his peers
he has teachers of course but the
teachers are vastly outnumbered by the
students
the child in public school learns how to
act what to say
what to believe largely by mimicking the
other kids in the school
his social success therefore from his
perspective his happiness
depends on his ability to fit in with
blendin with imitate
the other kids but the problem is that
the other kids are just as confused and
lost as he is
they're looking to him for cues he's
looking back at them
and together they travel around in
circles around and around going nowhere
all of the kids looking to all the other
kids for guidance attention and approval
this is socialization sure but it's a
form of socialization
uncomfortably reminiscent of like lord
of the flies
a book that i read in public school and
found myself thinking way too often as i
read it
wow i can really relate to this so what
about homeschool
well in homeschool the child spends most
of his time around his parents and his
siblings
there is a much better chance in this
environment that he picks up his social
cues from his parents
he looks to them for guidance
affirmation approval
if a homeschool child seems weird to you
it's probably because they're more
mature
more socially advanced than the typical
child
they've learned how to act how to
conduct themselves by imitating adults
that may make it more difficult for them
to fit in with some of their more
immature peers but in the long run
the benefits are clear and it's not like
homeschool kids pandemic
non-withstanding never spend any time
around other kids
it's just that they don't spend all of
their time around other kids that's a
good thing
and that's why the socialization
argument against homeschool is a big
fat lie